Let's consider now
a little more carefully
how we map trading to an RL problem.
So first of all the environment
here is really the market.
Our state that we're going to consider
includes things like market features,
prices, whether we're holding the stock.
I'll list a few of
those items right here.
Our actions are things like buy and
sell, and
potentially do nothing is
also an allowable action.
So let's think about
this in the context of
trying to learn how to
trade a particular stock.
So we've got this
historical time series, and
let's say this vertical line is today.
Now we can look back over time
to infer the state of the stock.
So what are the Ballinger Band
values and things like that.
Now we process that and
decide what's our action.
Let's suppose that we decide to buy.
So once we buy, we're now holding long.
That's part of our state.
We go forward, we're now on a new
state where the price has gone up.
We're holding long, let's suppose
we decide to sell at that point.
So we've had two actions,
well we've been in two states in
state one we were not holding.
We executed the action by,
went forward in time,
we're holding along now, and
then we execute the action sell.
Note that we made money here and
that's our reward, r.
So just to recap for a moment.
The policy that we learn tells us what
to do at each time we evaluate state,
and we're going to learn
that we haven't talked yet
about how we learned the policy.
But we're going to learn the policy
by looking at how we accrue money or
don't based on the actions
we take in the environment.